The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I wanted to
begin by just picking up
a couple of things
from last time.
This is part of
our sneaky agenda
of trying to teach you some
probability as we go along.
This is maybe a
little less crucial
than other things
we've been doing,
but to make sense of the
last couple of slides
from last time,
there was actually
stuff I swept under the rug
that it won't hurt you to know.
Just a reminder,
we talked last time
about the PDF of
a random variable.
I neglected to explicitly say
that about something that's
got to be non-negative
for all values of x.
And the reason is that if
the area under this thing
is going to be the
probability for any interval,
no matter how small,
if the area under it
is going to be the probability
that the random variable falls
in that interval, since
probabilities have
to be non-negative, well, this
function itself had better
be non-negative.
OK?
So that's an explicit
condition, and then there's
the normalization.
The question now is,
if you're dealing
with multiple random variables,
how does the story change?
So if you've got two random
variables, let's say x and y,
so two things that can
take numerical values,
say height and weight of
a randomly picked person.
We use a very analogous object.
It's the joint PDF of
the two random variables.
So it's some function of
two variables, non-negative,
so you can imagine it
like some probability
mass that sits on the plane
normalized to unit area.
And the amount of mass over
any particular piece of area
tells you what
the probability is
that you fall in that region.
So the expected value, we talked
about how to get expected value
in the single dimensional case.
In the 2-D case, it's a
natural generalization.
So the expected value of a
function of x and y, just
take that function under
the integral signs,
so you're taking an average
with respect to the PDF.
OK?
So it's a very
natural extension.
This is for the case
of two variables,
and in the same way
for m variables.
Now last time, I talked about a
very special case that involved
multiple random variables.
These were the random
variables corresponding
to the noise samples.
So we sent out a nice
clean looking signal.
This was our x of n.
And then what we received was
something that was perturbed.
And so we would
have liked to get
in the noise-free case the
same thing, but what we got
was this perturbed by a
certain random amount.
So the wi's this was
w1, for instance.
It's the amount that you add on
or subtract from a given value
to get the actually
received values.
OK?
OK.
So these are the wi's or wn's.
So we had multiple
random variables
because we were taking many
samples in the bit slot.
And in particular, we
looked at taking the average
of a bunch of measurements.
But now, what you've
got is a function
of many random variables.
So what does it mean to take
the expected value of a function
of many variables?
What does it mean to find
the variance of that?
Well, we didn't actually
get into the details of it.
But it turns out, there's
special structure here
that made those
computations very simple.
So one key thing was we said
that these noise samples were
independent from one
time incident to another.
And that's really
the crucial thing.
The other piece was just for--
well, it made sense for
our application because
of the central limit
theorem, but we
assumed that these noise
samples were Gaussian
with varying sigma squared.
There's a term I
didn't use, by the way,
for this kind of noise, but
you'll see it in the notes.
It's what's referred to as
additive white Gaussian noise.
The additive part is clear.
The white means
that it's IID noise.
The reasons for that
name become clear
when you think about
frequency domain,
so we won't get into
the origins of the name.
But the key thing
here is that these are
independent random variables.
So we should have actually been
talking about the joint density
of all these random
variables when
it came to computing expected
values and variances.
But it turns out that there are
actually some simplification,
so I'm just going to
give two statements which
are the things I want
you to carry away.
One is that expectation
is always additive.
So when you take the
expected value of--
I'm doing this for the case
of two random variables
by the way, but the
same thing goes for m.
If you've got the expectation
of a sum of two functions
of these random variables
that you're interested in,
the result is the sum of
the individual expectations.
And that's just the
consequence of the fact
that expectation is defined
through integrals and integrals
are additive in their
arguments, in the integrands.
Right?
So that's all that's
involved there.
Now, the particular
use we make of it
is for actually for a
sum of this kind where
one of the functions
is a function of just
one of the random variables,
the other function
is a function of just the
other random variable.
And so if you apply
the result up there,
you get sum of the expectations.
And the nice thing now
is that each of these
is just a 1-D expectation.
So we never have to
deal with joint PDFs,
joint distributions, multiple
integrals, and so on.
It all stays as simple
as the 1-D case.
And the reason is
that in every instance
we talk about, when we
have the expectation
of a sum of functions of
multiple random variables,
well, the sum actually involves
functions, each of which
is a function of only one
of those random variables.
So it actually becomes
very easy to compute.
Here's another thing that's
interesting with expectations,
which is that under
independence, you can actually
have expectations
be multiplicative.
In fact, let's see,
so the expected value
of the product of
a function of just
one of the random variables
and a function of just
the other factors
into the product
of the individual expectations
if these two random variables
are independent.
So that, again,
ends up being used.
For instance, when you're
computing the variance of,
let's say, w1 plus w2,
so the variance of this
is going to involve computing--
this is the 0 mean case.
So you'll find that
you're computing
the expected value of
w1 squared and then
the expected value
of w2 squared.
And then you've got twice
the expected value of w1 w2.
OK?
So while this is easy,
this is sigma squared,
this is sigma squared, what
do we do with this term?
Well, if it was a
general function of two
random variables,
then you've got
to pull in the joint density,
and it becomes a big operation.
But if these are independent,
then this expectation
factors into the product
of the individual ones.
These are 0 mean
random variables.
And so this goes to 0.
OK?
So this kind of computation
was going on in the results
I quoted or claimed
in the last lecture,
and I just wanted you
to have that in mind.
OK.
But what I really want to
talk about for the rest
of the lecture is going back
to understanding and modeling
the single link.
So we'll leave the probabilistic
stuff and that for now.
OK.
So we're back to
this picture of bits
coming in, being
converted to signals.
The signals are in
discrete time here.
They're being adapted
then to transmit
on an analog channel,
which has the noise in it,
and then at the other
end back to discrete time
through an inverse kind of
operation and out to bits
again.
So we're going to look
in more detail at what
goes on in there.
What we did with all our
noise analysis last time
was really focused on this
box where the decision is.
Right?
You get a noisy
sample and you're
trying to decide what you have.
So the lecture last time
was focused on that box,
and we're going to look at
the other parts of the picture
this time.
OK.
So the digitized symbols that we
talk about, here's an example.
We saw this last time.
So what you're doing
is taking the bitstream
and deciding that you're
going to represent it,
for instance, as a voltage one
held for a number of samples
to indicate a 1, a voltage of
0 held for a number of samples
to indicate a 0, and so on.
OK?
So this is the signal that you
want to get across the channel.
And then at the other
end, that signal
will get interpreted
as a string of bits.
OK?
When you do the
optimal detection
that we talked about last time.
So this link actually has--
it's a very hybrid kind
of thing because you've
got clock discrete time
stuff happening here.
This is a digital-to-analog
converter,
so you're going from
clock discrete time
to continuous time.
You typically have a
continuous analog channel.
And then at this
end, again, back
to discrete time, so
analog to digital.
Digital, by the way,
we use that word a lot.
What we typically mean is
something gets sampled,
it's a discrete time signal, and
there's often the implication
that it's quantized to
one of a set of levels.
It's basically the signal
you'll deal with in a processor
whereas all of this
is the signal that you
deal with in the physics,
in the analog part.
OK.
Then you're back to
the screen time here.
And actually, there are
two clocks even there
because there's a
particular clock that drives
all of this signal processing.
But then when you come
to spitting out the bits,
you're only going to spit
on one bit per bit slot.
So you've got many
samples per bit slot,
and then when you
come all the way out,
you're only going to report
one number, a 1 or a 0
per bit slot.
OK?
So there's all of this mixed
together in the system.
All right.
So let's look at the
particular case you're
going to be seeing in lab.
I put this up on the
slides last time as well.
So we're going to talk
about the specific case
of a channel that's just
an acoustic channel.
So we're going to
have sound coming out
of a loudspeaker, that's your
transmitter, sound getting
picked up in a microphone, and
that's your receiver, and then
all of the signal processing.
OK?
So labs four through
six are going
to be centered around this.
So the challenge then is taking
the digitized symbols there
and putting them to
a physical channel.
So what is it that
happens in between?
Let's see.
The D to A converter, we
don't say much about that,
but a typical D
to A converter is
taking a sequence of samples
which are just numbered
and then converting the samples
to a continuous waveform, which
is on a time axis.
So a discrete time sequence is
typically on an integer axis,
but we convert in a D to A
converter, what typically
happens is that
you're converting this
to a continuous time waveform.
And the simplest way to
do that is through what's
called a zero order hold.
So you take the value here, hold
it for some interval of time,
t seconds, and you
take the next value,
you hold it for t
seconds and so on.
And then when you get
a change in value,
you change to the new value.
So you would hold this here, and
then come down here, hold it.
So at the end of
it, what you've done
is convert a discrete time
sequence into a continuous time
waveform that can then
be applied to something
like the loudspeaker.
Right?
So you'll have to
specify in the D
to A converter what your
reconstruction interval is.
This kind of a D to
A converter would
be called a zero order hold.
Zero order because it just
looks at the most recent sample
and holds it.
A first order hold would
look at the last two samples
and do a linear projection.
So you can imagine
more elaborate ways
of doing the
digital-to-analog conversion.
So what I want you to imagine
is that when we get to the DAC
finally, it's going to
be something like this.
So all my pictures will be
discrete time sequences,
and I won't say much
about what goes on here.
So I want you to
imagine that whenever
I have a sequence like this,
and then I end up putting it
on the physical channel, there's
been a conversion of the state.
OK?
That's what you're
D do A card will do
in the computer at this point.
So you feed it a
bunch of numbers.
You give it a sampling rate
or a reconstruction rate.
And then it does this
kind of interpolation.
OK.
So let's see.
Is this a good voltage
to put on a loudspeaker?
If I wanted to signal a one
or a whole series of ones,
do I want to put a constant
voltage on a loudspeaker?
A loud speaker is not very happy
getting a DC voltage on it.
Right?
So the point is
here that you have
to think about your
transmission medium
and what its happiest
responding to.
So you've got to adapt your
signal to the capabilities
of the physical medium.
And that's what modulation is
all about, or at least that's
a key part of it.
Another part of modulation,
we'll see later,
is to allow you to have multiple
users share the same channel.
But a big part of it is
just adapting your signal
to a form that is
comfortable for the channel.
So here's what you might try
in the case of the loudspeaker.
So what you've got is
the acoustic channel.
You would like to transmit
these two levels, v0 and v1,
to represent the 0 and the 1.
I'm just generalizing here.
I'm just saying that there's
some level v0 that represents
the 0 and there's
some level of v1,
and I will allow you to pick
different possibilities here.
So what's typically done is
instead of trying to transmit
the DC, you transmit
a burst of a sinusoid
because loud speakers
like sinusoids
provided they're at
the right frequency.
So again, you've got
to think about what
frequency makes sense.
It's this cone trying
to move a massive air
to try to make a
massive air oscillate.
There are particular frequencies
that are good for that,
so you have to think about that.
So you might, for instance, say
that you want sinusoidal bursts
at two kilohertz,
and you're going
to modulate the amplitude.
So you'll send a burst v0 cosine
2 pi of ct to represent the 0,
and you'll send a burst
of v1 cosine 2 pi of ct
to represent the 1.
So if it's simple on-off keying
that we've been talking about,
you'll have v0 equals 0.
In other words, you'll signal
a 0 by sending nothing out
on the loudspeaker.
And then when you
want to signal a 1,
you'll have a cosine
of amplitude capital V.
In the other case
here, what you do
is you have minus v cosine going
out to signal a 0 and plus v
cosine going out to signal a 1.
So that's basically just a
180 degree change of phase.
Every time you want to shift
from a 1 to a 0 or a 0 to a 1,
you're going to change
the phase by 180 degrees.
That changes the sign.
Right?
Because it's fixed amplitude,
and you step the phase
each time you want to change.
So this would be a
natural way to do it.
Why two kilohertz?
Well we know that this
is the kind of frequency
that a loud speaker likes.
And the more
general principle is
whenever you're
trying to radiate
energy, the size of the
antenna that you use,
the antenna element
that you use,
for efficient
transfer of power, has
to be comparable with the
wavelength of the signal
that you have.
So for instance, if
you're talking about sound
at two kilohertz, the
speed of sound and air
at room temperature is
something on that order
340 meters per second.
If you do the computation
of the wavelength,
and I always do
it with the units,
so I may get it wrong here.
But 340 meters per second,
and for wavelength,
I know that I want the
answer to come out in meters.
I've got two kilohertz,
so I've got to divide
by 2000 per second.
Right?
That's the units of
frequency, and that's going
to give me something in meters.
And if I wanted to come
out in centimeters,
then it's 340 divided
by 20, so that's 17.
And, well, 17 is in the
ballpark for the dimensions
of a speaker.
You actually-- it depends on
the details of how this is done,
but you might be
satisfied with a quarter
wavelength of the transmission.
Quarter wavelength of
17 is really very well
within the range of what a
speaker might be on a laptop,
depending on the size
of your laptop, I guess.
OK.
So all of this goes on
in trying to figure out
how to modulate the
signal onto a channel.
So these are instances, actually
the very simple instances,
of what's called
amplitude modulation.
Actually, in the
very first lecture,
I mentioned when we were
trying to distinguish
analog communication from
digital communication,
I said that the typical analog
communication scheme might
be AM, amplitude modulation,
where you take a carrier
and you modulate its amplitude.
And the amplitude is what
carries the information.
So this would be something
of the type x of t
cosine 2 pi of ct.
All right.
So it's a carrier,
which is a pure cosine,
and you have an amplitude
that slowly varying.
And it's the amplitude that
carries the information
for the analog communication.
So the receiver
what would be done
is figure out some way of
extracting the envelope here.
All right?
That's classic AM.
Ours is a very simple case
where we're saying rx of t
is either 0 or v in the
case of on-off keying,
or it's a minus v or plus v
in the case of bipolar keying.
But it's still on the
AM kind of modulation.
OK.
So what I have up
here is actually just
to remind you that this also
happened in the neighborhood
here.
This is Fessenden in 1906
is credited on Christmas Eve
with making the first
voice transmission,
wireless voice transmission,
as opposed to Morse
code transmissions which
had been around for a while.
And what was his oscillator?
Well, what was his antenna?
It was this 420 foot thing,
that's about, I think,
about 120 meters.
So if you actually put
in the speed of light,
you'll see what
kind of antenna size
you need, sorry, what
kind of frequency
you need to excite this
with for the wavelength
to be the comparable to
the size of the antenna.
So let's see, 3 times 10
to the 8 is speed of light,
and I've got an antenna
that's 120 meters.
So let's say 10 to the 2,
so it's about 3 times 10
to the 6 Hertz that I need
to be exciting this at.
Well, he wasn't able to
get anywhere near that.
He actually had this
big electrical machine
that could generate a
sinusoid of about 50 kilohertz
for which he'd have needed a
much taller antenna to have
efficient transmission,
but it was
enough for the signal
to be picked up
a few kilometers away.
And he claimed that it
was heard all the way
down the coast of
Virginia and so on,
but there's some
controversy about that.
Anyway, he's credited
with developing
a lot of the basic
technology for AM
and for developing these
machines and all of that.
I like the name of the
cocktail named in his honor
by the city of Marshfield.
Here's a picture of the
antenna from an old postcard.
Looks very Cape Cod
and Marshfield-y.
He had a companion, a
system built in Scotland,
but a careless workman,
at one point, disconnected
a particular cable that
was tying it to the ground,
and the whole tower collapsed.
So his transatlantic experiments
were set back for a while.
OK.
So how is this done?
Well, for our setting,
it's actually quite easy.
We've got our digitized
symbols coming out here.
This is the x of n,
something like this
if we're doing
bipolar signaling.
And we're going to
multiply it by a cosine.
So here's our cosine carrier.
We'll use capital omega
to denote frequency
in these discrete time signals.
And I'm using angular
frequency, so this is 2 pi times
whatever other frequency you're
used to thinking in terms of,
but this is typical for
discrete time signals.
And so this is
what it looks like.
This is for the specific case
of the x event I showed earlier.
So let me flip back
to show you that.
This one.
OK?
So we're taking this waveform
and multiplying it by cosine.
So what you're going to have is
a burst of cosine and then 0,
then a longer burst
of cosine and then 0,
and then a burst of
cosine and then 0,
and then a burst
of cosine again.
So that's what
we're seeing here.
OK.
A short burst of cosine.
This is 16 samples long
and then 32 samples of 0
and then 48 samples
of cosine and so on.
All right?
So your loudspeaker is emitting
power and then turning off
and emitting power
and turning off,
and this is what gets
picked up by the microphone.
So the microphone
has to figure out--
this is the particular case
of an on-off signaling scheme.
So the microphone has to
figure out what's being sent.
OK.
So any particular thoughts on
how you might recover things
at the receiving end?
So what I'm not
showing you is the D
to A converter, which is
going to take this thing
and interpolate these points and
put it out on real time access
and put it out on the channel.
OK?
I'm imagining all of this
kind of stuff going on,
but we're just going to
look from discrete signal
to discrete signals,
so I'm suppressing
all the stuff in between.
So at the other
end, you somehow--
let me assume there was no
distortion on the channel,
and you figured out a way to
get exactly this after sampling
at the receiving end.
If you got the signal,
what might you do to it
to recover those 0 and 1?
Any particular ideas?
If you had to write an
algorithm to do that?
So I'm saying imagine no
distortion on your channel.
You hear a sound
on your microphone,
you take samples of it,
you get a signal like this,
and now you've got to decode.
Anything?
It ought to be pretty simple.
Right?
Yeah.
STUDENT: Take the absolute
value [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: OK,
yeah, I like that.
So let's take the
absolute value.
So you might get
something like this.
And then there's a gap, and then
you get something like this,
and so on.
Right?
I'm drawing these as
though they're continuous,
but actually, what you're
getting is a bunch of samples.
And these are supposed to
be sections of sinusoid.
This is what we call
a rectified sinusoid.
The electrical
engineers say rectified,
it's just taking
the absolute value.
Right?
Once you have this, you're
probably in better shape
to try and figure out
where there is signal
and where there is not.
So what could you do?
What might you try doing?
Felix?
You want to continue?
What's the next step?
STUDENT: So you can take the
moving maximum [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you're saying, let's
have a sliding window
of some kind that looks to
see how much of the signal
is in there.
Is there any window
size that will actually
give you a constant signal if
you're in the body of this?
I mean, if you took a window
that was equal to a period
here, this is periodic.
Right?
While the sinusoid is
ringing, its periodic.
So if you took a
window of this size
and then slid it along, at
least in the body of this,
you're going to get a
constant because you're
picking up the average value
of the rectified sinusoid.
And then near the
ends, you're going
to get some effects
whatever they are.
But that should be
enough to give you
a good stretch of signal.
And again, you're not getting
a continuous green thing,
you're actually getting samples.
Right?
But that should
be enough to help
you figure out where you have
zeros and where you have ones.
So very simple.
What if we have
a bipolar scheme?
Suppose we have a signal
that can be plus or minus.
And so what we have
is not this, but we
have a phase change every
time we go from a 1 to 0.
Then, if you take
the absolute value,
you've lost all the information.
Right?
So we've got to figure
out something else.
OK.
So the more general
way to do this,
for instance, for the case
where you have the bipolar
transmission, is--
well, this is actually just to--
it turns out that I had
the same idea as you did,
which was take
absolute value and then
a local average
over a half period.
It's a very natural
thing to think
of as a way to extract that.
That works for the on-off
signaling, but for the bipolar,
it's a little trickier.
So here's what a typical
general demodulation
scheme is for amplitude
modulated signals.
Here's the transmitted signal.
It's been received.
I've converted it from
analog to digital and so on.
I'm going to do the
same thing again.
I'm going to multiply
it locally by a cosine
at the same frequency.
So I have a local
oscillator at my receiver
that's got the same frequency
as the carrier frequency that
was used for transmission.
OK?
When you tune your radio
on AM, what you're doing
is actually adjusting the
local oscillator frequency
to match that of the
station frequency.
OK.
And the station
frequencies, by the way,
should be obvious by now
when you have, what is it,
820 AM or whatever,
what they're announcing
is the frequency
of their carrier.
That's how they're known.
They're known by the
frequency of the carrier.
OK.
So here's what the result is.
You've got the signal
that you transmitted
multiplied by the cosine.
What's the signal
that you transmitted?
Well it was the signal
you wanted to get across
but multiplied by the carrier
at the transmitting end.
OK.
You've got the
cosine squared there.
We have a standard identity
for cosine squared.
That's half of 1 plus
cosine twice the angle.
Right?
Yeah?
STUDENT: What if you're
given a phase shift?
PROFESSOR: OK, yeah.
Good question.
The question is what if you
have a phase shift because this
assumes not just that you
have the right frequency
but that you have
exactly the right phase.
And it turns out
that that's something
that has to be dealt with.
So there are mechanisms
for doing that.
So basically, what
you end up doing
in one way of tackling that
is you multiply by cosine,
you multiply by a sine.
And by looking at the
outputs of both of those,
you can actually figure out
what the right phase shift is.
So that's a good question.
It's not just phase
shift, there's
also time delays and
propagation and so on,
so it's a real issue.
But let's just deal with
the simplest case for now.
OK.
So what you have after the
multiplication is something
that actually has the
signal you're interested in,
that first part, just scaled
by a factor of a half,
and then it's got some
stuff that you don't want.
It's got a double
frequency component which
you have to try and get rid of.
But the nice thing
here is if you
were able to get rid of the
double frequency component,
then you have x of n
there whether or not
it's plus or minus.
So the sign is not lost.
It's not the absolute value of
x anymore that we're recovering,
it's the actual x.
So your x can go
positive or negative,
and you'll pull it out.
OK?
So this is better than just
taking the absolute value
and doing a local filtering.
OK.
So here's what that looks like
for the particular example
we have.
So you can see the double
frequency cosine over here,
and then the average value
that that cosine is riding on
is going between 1 and 0
in this particular case.
OK?
So this was a 0-1 waveform
that we transmitted,
but we're demodulating
it using a scheme that
could have actually handled
a signal that went negative
as well.
But this example doesn't have
a signal that goes negative.
It was the one that
I showed you earlier.
But you can see that the average
value here is picking out
exactly what you want.
So your challenge
now is to get rid
of the double frequency piece.
So does someone want to
suggest to me how you
might do that computationally?
Yeah.
STUDENT: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
STUDENT: If you wanted to extend
[INAUDIBLE] by extra sign,
why don't we want to
multiply by it again?
PROFESSOR: Oh, I see
what you're saying.
What you're saying is, we could
have done this more simply
if what came in--
that's a good question.
We could just
divide by the cosine
here and get what we want
because what went down
was the transmitted
times the cosine.
I never thought of that.
Could there be a
problem with it?
STUDENT: Maybe if
cosine has a value of 0.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you see the point is that
the cosine has multiple zero
crossings.
And in the discrete
time case, of course,
it depends on what
that frequency is.
You might not go
exactly through 0.
But then you're going to be
horrendously sensitive to noise
and other things in the system.
So that's a good thought.
It's like in the Viterbi case,
by the way, if you're not
thinking of noise, then
the very simple ways
to combine the parity
stream to recover the input.
But as soon as there's some
noise, all of this falls apart.
So the scheme is robust
up to a point to noise.
I mean, only up to
a point, you know
if you've listened
to AM radio that it
can get annoyingly noisy,
but up to a point, it's fine.
OK.
So we were here,
and I was asking,
how might you get rid of that
double frequency component?
Any ideas?
Someone who hasn't
spoken today maybe?
I want to do some filtering
operation on this.
I want to run some
algorithm on this that's
going to eliminate the
double frequency piece
and just get me the
nice waveform back.
Yeah.
STUDENT: You can
do the same thing.
PROFESSOR: I can
OK.
So what interval
would I pick then?
STUDENT: It would be not
the double frequency,
the single frequency.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I could get away
with, let's see,
I could get away with the
period of the double frequency.
Right.
If it was equal to the period of
the double frequency component,
then as if I take the
average with that,
then I've got a full cycle of
the double frequency component,
and it will go off to 0.
Right?
So that's what I need to do.
And that's the
simplest way to do it.
So the filter here,
the simplest one,
just puts out a signal that sums
L plus 1 of these values where
L plus 1 is 8.
That's exactly the period of
the double frequency component.
Remember, we had 16 samples
for the original carrier,
so double frequency
component has a period of 8.
And so the 2 omega
piece gets eliminated,
and here's what we get.
OK.
So there's some
transition at the ends
because when you get to the
ends of something like this,
and you're doing the
averaging, well, now you've
got a little bit of
the previous bits
worth and a little bit of
the current bits worth,
so there's going
to be a transition.
But it'll still leave
you with plenty of room
in which to make your
decision as to what you have.
OK.
So now what I want to do
for the rest of the lecture,
and we're going to
continue is well
into the next few lectures,
is say we've understood,
at least at some
level, how you might
get across the analog channel.
So let's now just focus
on input to output here.
So we've got a discrete
time signal here,
and I get a discrete time
signal coming out there.
And I can think of that as
my channel input and output.
I can suppress all
this other stuff.
Knowing that all
of that goes on,
but in terms of
my designing what
I want to do with the signals, I
can just look at it end-to-end.
So we're going to talk about
models for end-to-end behavior
from the discrete
time sequence that
goes in to the
discrete time sequence
that you reconstruct
at the other end.
OK?
So abstractly, what we
have is some system,
S. We've got an input
sequence, an output sequence.
And this is typically how
these things are drawn.
I just want to
caution you on this.
When you see a
diagram like this,
you want to think
of it as a snapshot
of the system at a time n.
You don't want to
think of it as saying
that the value of y at the
output at some particular time
n is determined by the value
of x at that same time n.
OK?
So the real story is that,
in general for such systems,
the value of the output
at any particular time n
is determined by all the
input values of the input.
If it's a causal
system, then it only
depends on the present
and past inputs.
But in some settings, you can
think about non-causal kind
of processing.
So in general, when you
see a picture like this,
think of it as a snapshot
of the system at time n.
But it's not telling you
that x and that one value
gets mapped to yn
that one value.
That's not what's happening.
I'm a little fuzzy about
this because, often, that's
glossed over, and then
it leads to confusion.
So more, generally,
if I want you
to be thinking of the
signal as a whole,
I'll use this notation.
I'll just put a dot there to
say it's the entire waveform
that I'm referring to because
I don't want you to fixate
on a particular time instant.
OK.
So that's our system.
Here's a little more
fussing about notation,
but I don't think I want
to bother with that now.
Please look at it when
you review the slides.
Let's go to talking about
some particular signals,
and these may be
ones you've seen
in 601 is convenient
signals to talk about.
We'll do a lot with
unit step functions.
So these are signals.
This is a signal that is
0 for all negative time.
And then at time 0, it
goes up to the value 1
and then stays at 1.
So that's the unit step.
And our standard notation
for it is u of n.
So when you see u of n, that's
what you want to imagine.
And u of n minus
3 then, well, this
will have the same value at
n equals 3 that this had at n
equals 0.
So the point of transition
for this waveform must be at n
equals 3.
OK?
So it's the same signal
but just delayed by 3.
So u of n minus 3 just has
it step three instance later.
Here's another very special
signal that we use a lot.
It's what's called the unit
sample function or unit sample
signal.
So it's an entire signal.
It's not just one value,
it's signal denoted
by the symbol delta of n.
It's 0 for all positive
and negative time.
But at time 0, it
has the value 1.
So that's the unit sample.
And so if you had, for
instance, delta of n plus 5,
it's the shifted version
of that function.
And what happened that n equals
0 here will now happen at n
equals minus 5.
In other words, the spike up
there is at n equals minus 5.
So we're going to need to get
comfortable with unit step
functions and their shifted
versions and the unit
sample functions and
their shifted versions.
OK.
And there's a relation
between the two as well.
So you should see fairly
clearly that you can actually
write the unit sample function
as a difference of a unit
step and a delayed unit step.
OK?
Now, we can do standard
algebraic operations
on signals.
So I can take a
unit step function.
I can do things like u of n
plus 3 times u of n minus 7.
And what this means is
draw the signal u of n.
Draw the signal 3 times u
of n minus 7, which is just
u of n minus 7, each
value scaled by 3,
and then just add them
instant by instant.
So it's the most natural
way of adding signals.
It's exactly what you would do
if you're adding or multiplying
the functions of continuous
time from your calculus course.
It's the same idea.
So we can do all of these
algebraic operations.
Now, the response of a system
to the unit step or the unit
sample is interesting.
It's not interesting for
all sorts of systems,
but it's interesting
for the class of systems
that we'll be focusing on.
So let's talk about that.
So the unit sample
response of a system
is just the output signal
that you get when the input
signal is the unit sample.
OK?
This is the traditional
symbol for it, h of n.
So when you see h of
n, you're typically
thinking of unit
sample response.
Similarly, the unit step
response, put in a unit step.
The signal that
you have the output
is the unit step response, and
we'll use the symbol s of n
for that.
So the reason that these
are useful in many contexts
is that you can take a
general signal, for instance,
the one at the top
there and represent it
as a weighted sum of scaled and
shifted unit sample functions.
OK?
So this is just saying I
can think of this function
as being advanced unit
samples scaled by something
and another one scaled
by something else
and another one scaled by
something else and so on.
Here is the analytical
expression that goes with that.
So any signal can be
thought of as being made up
of a bunch of unit samples
appropriately scaled
and appropriately delayed.
The same thing with
the unit steps.
And these are waveforms,
as you've seen.
This is the kind
of waveform we work
with a lot in the
context of communication.
So we've got these sorts
of rectangular waveforms.
And it's very useful to think
of them as being combinations
of unit steps.
So the waveform
at the top can be
generated by having a unit
step at this time climbing up.
And then I've got to
calculate its effect
on this next transition, so I
put a negative going unit step.
And I want to bring it
back up again at that time,
so I put another
unit step and so on.
So you can synthesize
a signal of this type
as a linear combination of
unit steps scaled and delayed.
Now, this is actually
important when
you get to particular classes
of systems for which you
can exploit these properties.
So let me tell you
what linearity is
and what time invariance is,
because the rest of our talk
about systems is going to be
focused on linear and time
invariant systems.
So let's start with what a
time invariant system is.
It's just a system whose
response to a given input
doesn't depend on
the day of the week
that you do the experiment.
If you come back tomorrow
and do the same experiment,
you'll get the same result
except it's happening
tomorrow instead of today.
Right?
So it's a system where
if you delayed the input
by some capital
N, the response is
the response you had
previously but just delayed
by the same amount.
So time invariant
system is one where
the response doesn't depend on
absolute position on the time
axis.
If you shift the
input by some amount,
you get the same response but
shifted by that same amount.
So it's a very easy idea.
OK.
So for instance, if you
had a time invariant system
and you put in a
delayed unit sample,
this is a unit sample that
has the value 1 at the point
capital N. Your response will
be the unit sample response
but correspondingly delayed.
Right?
So time invariance of a
system allows you to do that,
and that's very convenient.
Here's the other property that's
crucial, which is linearity.
And we've talked about
linearity a lot along the way.
Here is a definition
in this context.
OK.
So we say no the
system S is linear
if you can do the following.
Take the response
y1 to an experiment
with an arbitrary input x1.
OK?
So you put in an arbitrary input
x1, you get the response y1.
Put in an arbitrary input
x2 and another experiment
get out the response y2.
If it's true that any
weighted linear combination
of those inputs from the
previous two experiments
will give rise to
a response that's
the same weighted combination
of the original responses,
then you have a linear system.
OK?
So if superposition
of inputs, according
to this formula
so a weighted sum,
leads to a response
and output, that's
the same weighted
combination, then what
you have is a linear system.
OK?
So if this is true for arbitrary
inputs and arbitrary scale
factors.
So one important conclusion
from that, by the way,
is if you have a
linear system, and you
put in the all-zero input,
the response must also
be an all-zero response.
And I'll leave you to think
about why that might be true.
OK.
So the systems that we are
going to be focusing on
will be linear and
time invariant.
OK?
LTI.
And so we're going
to be thinking
of end-to-end models of the
channel, our digitized sequence
xn, all the way through
the processing that
happened in between.
OK, so what did we have?
We had modulate.
We had D to A conversion.
We had the channel.
We had A to D. We had DMod.
And there was a
filtering operation,
as well, there as part
of the demodulation.
So all of that,
end-to-end, we're
going to try representing that
as a linear time invariant
model.
So it'll be an approximation.
Real channels are
more complicated.
But it turns out that
LTI is a very good place
to start, and not just for
the communication setting,
for a whole variety of settings.
So it turns out
that if you're just
talking about small deviations
from some nominal operating
point, a linear
model is not bad.
And the reason is,
well, it goes back
to Taylor series
kinds of thinking.
You can have a very
non-linear function,
but if you're looking in the
neighborhood of some operating
point--
stick it up there.
So here's some operating
point, and you're only
looking at small
perturbations around there.
The linear approximation
is not a bad one.
OK?
So it's really essentially
that idea that first order
Taylor series kinds of
approximations are good.
And so linearity works.
Time invariance works because
many systems are inherently
time invariant.
Now, that's not always true
for communication channels.
If you've got a mobile
device, for instance,
the channel is
changing all the time.
Well, if you're mobile
with your mobile device,
the channel is
changing all the time.
So you need to reckon
with time varying channels
or what are called
fading channels.
But for many situations,
a time invariant channel
is reasonable.
So time invariant and linear
is a good approximation.
Now, as soon as you invoke
linearity and time invariance,
you've got such a rich
structure that opens up
that there's a lot you
can do by way of analysis
and developing computational
tools and so on.
And that gives you a very
good handle on doing design.
So if you're trying to design
something that's, ideally,
linear time invariant,
you have a large array
of tools at your disposal.
So you'll find that
in engineered systems,
people are trying to design
modules that are thought
about as LTI systems and then
interconnecting them, maybe,
in non-linear ways
or time varying ways.
OK.
We'll pick up on this
in recitation tomorrow
and next lecture which will
be Wednesday of next week.
And make sure you're aware
of what the portions are
for the quiz and
where you have to go
for the quiz rooms and all
of that on Thursday evening
next week.